One limitation of many measures of personality is that they rely on conscious
verbal assessments. However, some theorists such as Sigmund Freud, believe that
much of our personality is actually unconscious and therefore difficult to
verbalize. > That's right. And Sigmund Freud was a very famous psychologist who
developed the psychoanalytic theory. And he thought that at the core of a
person's personality was the unconscious mind. Their thoughts, motives and
drives as opposed to the conscious mind.
>> Followers of Freud actually developed indirect measures of our unconscious
needs and motives. They believed that dreams and fantasies actually revealed a
lot about the unconscious mechanisms behind personality.
>> Now, these techniques are known as projective tests. And that's because a
person's unconscious thoughts, motives, and drives, are projected onto their
answers.
>> The key with projective test is, you have to give a person a stimulus that's
really ambiguous. That way, it can be interpreted in many different ways.